-Guys, it is time for
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
Here we go.
-♪ Hashtags ♪
♪♪
♪ Hashtags ♪
-All right.
Now, we do this thing every week
where I send out a hashtag,
and we ask you guys
to respond to that topic.
This week, I sent out a hashtag,
#AddAWordRuinAHorrorMovie.
I asked you to take
a horror movie title,
add one word
to change the meaning.
Within minutes,
it was the number-one
trending topic in the U.S.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Number-one on Twitter.
So thank you for playing along.
Now I thought Jack and I would
share some of our favorite
"Add a word, ruin a horror
movie" tweets from you guys.
You ready for this?
-Yes.
-All right, here we go.
I'll go first.
This first is from
@patsysweetie.
She says...
[ Laughter ]
I like that kid.
-That kid's cute.
-Yeah, he liked "cone."
-It's got the juice.
-Okay.
This one's -- you read this.
-This is from @Joanosborne.
-The real -- by the way,
the singer,
the real Joan Osborne
sent in this, yeah.
-She says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
That's my type of television
right there.
-Yeah, that's pretty good.
That's decently scary.
Yeah, yeah.
This one's from @Webhead62.
He says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ As Statham ] "Oi, you're not
wearing a hockey mask, mate?
Huh?
You like killing people, huh?
On Friday the 13th?"
No, oh, no.
"When it's a nightmare.
Oi.
Oi, you like --
you like nightmares?"
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] Jason Statham,
I sat next to him once
at some charity event
we were at.
And I sat next to him,
and he goes, "Oi, what you do?"
[ Laughter ]
I go, "I'm a talk-show host."
He goes, "I don't
really like chat shows."
[ Laughter ]
I go, "Well, it was
nice to meet you, man."
[ Laughter ]
I go, "You know,
we don't have to talk.
We can play games on the show
or whatever."
He goes, "You play games?"
I go, "Yeah, yeah,
we play games."
"What kind of games
do you play?"
I go, "We play anything.
We play beer pong.
We play water war."
He's like, "What's water war?"
I go, "It's like war
but you throw water."
He's like, "I'll play a game."
[ Laughter ]
I go, "All right."
And then, the next week,
he came on the show.
Like, I don't even think
he was supposed to be here,
but he just showed up.
We were like, "All right.
Come on, on."
-He like it?
-He was so funny.
We were laughing
like little kids,
and I had to throw water
in Jason Statham's face.
-Must have been amazing.
-It was the most
frightening thing
I've ever done in my lifetime.
[ Laughter ]
'Cause at one point, I go,
"He's gonna punch me."
I think he was balling his fist.
But then
he just started laughing.
We had the best time ever.
I love Jason Statham.
He's invited back any time.
-Shout-out Jason Statham.
-Yeah, he's a good man.
Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
All right.
How about that one?
-@superkmdc.
She says...
[ Laughter ]
-That'd be frightening
to have those Chia Pets
come back to life, yeah.
Yeah.
-I wouldn't be afraid.
[ Laughter ]
-A bunch of
Richard Simmons heads.
-Yeah.
-This one's from @werehawk1.
He says...
Oh, that's interesting.
[ Laughter ]
That's funny.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
"Five Nights at Freddy's."
-Freddie Mercury.
-It's a game.
-I know Freddie Mercury.
I don't know the --
-Five Nights at Freddy's --
It's not a movie, actually,
but it's a game.
Where you gotta, like --
you're in a store,
and there's an animatronic bear,
and you got to --
[ Laughter ]
-It's like an '80s game.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-My fault.
Like a '70s game, like...
-No, no, no.
It's a now game.
-Yeah.
All the kids are playing it.
-Kids are playing it.
-I'm sure.
-Skateboarding with
their hats on backwards.
-All the kids watching, let us
know if you're playing that.
[ Laughter ]
-They do!
I'm telling you.
Oh, my gosh.
I feel so old.
Here we go.
-I want this one.
-All right, good.
Take that.
-All right.
Geez.
Josh94247546.
[ Laughter ]
-That's a great handle.
-546?
-Nah, nah.
-I hate that handle.
-It's just Josh.
Josh...
[ Laughter ]
-That's classic Josh.
-He says...
-Ah! That's pretty good.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
I like that.
Yeah, "Se7en-11" is pretty good.
At the end, they open the box.
You know what it is?
-Taquitos.
-Yeah, old taquitos.
[ Laughter ]
That's exactly what it is.
Old taquitos.
This one's from @trunkboy82.
He says...
[ Laughter ]
-Oh.
-"Get Out" more.
"Get out more."
Yeah.
Uh, all right.
-[ Laughs ]
-This last one here --
Check this one out.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, I like this.
-Okay.
-@TheHonl.
He says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Smothered and covered.
"The Last Waffle House
on the Left."
There you have it.
Those are our
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
To check out
more of our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.